so this channel is about spreading truth
I also talk about ancient civilizations
talk about all kinds of different things
in this channel we're about to share
with you the Tao Te Ching is absolutely
worth your time and real quick before
you press the back button picking out
ways this is a video about a book how
lame no this is worth your time it's the
best 599 I've ever spent in my life on
Amazon and it's 81 chapters long however
you can read it in 20 minutes because
like most chapters are quite literally
this long the longest is this one
nothing exceeds one page and it's so
much freaking truth when you read it you
just know it's like the gospel so to
speak but yeah there's a lot of history
behind this book no one knows who wrote
it or when other than that it originated
thousands of years ago in China and it
makes many mentions throughout the
chapters about the ancients and how they
knew the way and that and that being
said that me that's the title of the
book it means the book of the way or the
book of the way of virtue and there's a
bunch of a different interpretations for
this book you find different authors
because they've spent so much time just
trying to decipher it trying to
translate it and interpret it so without
further ado I'm going to read eight
passages I know that sounds lame someone
reading a book gun YouTube video like
how dumb is that but they're super quick
and it will paint you a picture so what
the books about and hopefully encourage
you to go buy it because quite literally
this entire free the human race would
improve overnight if everybody read this
specially world leaders so let me skip
I'm going I'll read the very last
chapter first eighty one which is titled
true words
you probably can't see that so let me
just get into it to get an idea two
words are often unpleasant pleasant
words are often untrue those who know
the truth do not argue those who argue
do not know the truth
scholars are seldom the wisest men and
wise men are seldom scholars those who
steal from others impoverish themselves
those who give to others become rich
those who fight do not win those who win
do not fight this is the way of the Tao
that's the last one let me skip over to
11 which is a materiality in materiality
to say that right yeah all right we all
may have thirty spokes but its
usefulness lies in the
d hub a jar is formed from clay but its
usefulness lies in the empty center a
room is made from four walls but its
usefulness lies in the space between in
the same way matter is necessary to give
form but the value of reality lies in
its immateriality that is everything
that lives has a physical body but the
value of life is measured by the soul
yeah you hear me talk about different
spiritual things on this channel and Bek
ties right into it let me skip to 40
which is non-existence which is the
shortest like a very short one our ear
we go
the Tao seems to be non-existent yet it
is essential heaven and earth and
everything in them are produced from
existence
but existence comes from non-existence
think about that it's kind of a mind
[ __ ] and like I said you read this whole
book in 20 minutes but I would encourage
you to spend a little bit longer so you
can reflect on the passages but I'm
going to keep going because I just want
to paint you a picture here and
encourage you to get it so 42 yin and
yang the Tao produces unity unity
produces duality duality produces
Trinity Trinity produces all things all
things contain both the negative
principle Yin and the positive
principles yang the third principle
energetic vitality Qi which I've talked
about energy and you're full of source
energy which is a video coming that I'm
going to make very soon makes them
harmonious there are some things which
it is a gain to lose and a loss to gain
this may not be what they teach in
school but is the first lesson in
learning the Tao pretty interesting when
you think about that 157 freedom this
one's a little bit longer yeah look how
long that is it's worth it though the
Empire is administered but with
righteousness the army is directed by
strategy the people are best ruled by
giving them freedom how do I know this
is so by the Tao the more restrictions
and prohibitions there are the poorer
people become the more soldier the more
soldiers patrol the streets the more the
city is in disorder the more the city is
in disorder the more officials are
crafty and cunning the heart of the
people are to control the
our laws and orders are issued the more
thieves armed robbers abound the wise
ruler says if I am practice excuse me if
I practice restraint the people will
reform themselves if I love peace the
people will become peaceful if I am not
greedy
the people will become prosperous if I
practice simplicity that people will
become simple like a men like that you
can see this going on in our own society
guys you see it happening all around the
world there is a lot of freaking truth
to that when you see just how big
governments have become and the
consequences behind them all right guys
I'm almost done let me share 71 which is
ignorant this one's fantastic to know
that there are some things that you
cannot know is mental health not to know
things that you ought to know is illness
the wise man recognizes the limits of
his knowledge the foolish man thinks he
knows everything a men not so you run a
YouTube channel you'll see some of the
comments you get you're like oh my god
like people think they know everything
everyone thinks they know everything
well not everyone enlighten people like
whoever wrote this surely understand it
all right just two more guys I'm
wrapping this up 75 oppression when
taxes are excessive the people starve
when officials are meddlesome the people
rebel when governments make life burns
burns them that people do not fear death
oppression never achieves its intended
results in that right very true all
right guys last one number 78
paradoxical truth nothing is gentler
than water yet nothing can withstand its
force
likewise nothing compares to the Tao by
it the weak defeat the strong the
flexible Conqueror the rigid everyone
knows this is true but how foot it into
practice priests are often the worst
sinners government officers are often
the worst criminals the truth is often
paradoxical again this is the tao
beijing i highly recommend it my most
favorite passages in their chapters i
didn't read this because they're a
little longer and I know how lame it is
to hear someone read on a YouTube video
so anyways guys I'm gonna wrap up there
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe help me spread the message
many more videos to come and a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody